let's ask a philosophical question what
is it that makes up a person's soul is
it their personality their memories
their emotions the history of their good
and bad deeds is it an energy that
inhabits a living body an active
consciousness or even all of the above
or is the soul just an entirely nebulous
and undefinable concept the idea of the
soul is almost as old as human
civilization itself with philosophers
from as far back as ancient greece and
even before acknowledging its existence
numerous religions from all over the
world if not all of them also hold
teachings about the nature of souls even
though they might vary for example
judaism and some denominations of
christianity state that only human
beings have an immortal soul that will
live on in heaven after a person's death
and the end of their time on earth
meanwhile certain catholic theologians
meaning people who study religion claim
that a soul inhabits all living
creatures and so the philosophical and
theological debate goes on with the
general consensus being that souls are
well they're a little bit of everything
every part of someone that makes them
who they are character emotions
reasoning consciousness memories and
thoughts all blended together but if we
accept that a soul is something that
exists then it is something that can be
altered is it constant or can it be
manipulated could a person's soul even
be removed entirely at first glance
scp-158 appears to be a device
resembling a mechanical arm in fact it's
a lot like the kind of machine you might
expect to find inside a huge factory
standing as part of an assembly line
welding and drilling components together
day in and day out
this particular mechanized arm however
features a number of unique and bizarre
differences from any currently used and
automated production for starters it has
an unusual attachment at one end a
three-prong tridactyl-like claw the arm
itself is also designed to be suspended
from the ceiling ideally hanging upside
down in a room big enough to accommodate
it there is a long series of winding
cables connecting scp-158 to a
complicated computer console that is
used to control the device while the
remaining cables are intended to be
connected to a power source as for the
console it possesses a visual display
unit and a keyboard like you might
expect it to and at the bottom there is
what appears to be some form of a
dispenser seemingly designed to attach
to a container of some kind measuring 3
inches wide by 7 inches tall the ideal
receptacle to fit the attachment is that
of a glass jar or beaker this mechanical
arm was first uncovered by the
foundation in late 2007 inside a burned
down hospital in an unknown location
that has been redacted from the scp-158
file the hospital itself was derelict
abandoned and appeared to have been
unused for a considerable period of time
approximately five years but perhaps
more agents working for the foundation
recovered scp-158
along with an owner's manual that
presumably would have contained detailed
instructions describing the device's
function and exactly how to operate it
this manual had been badly damaged by
the fire but the readable portions of it
were later transcribed and copied and
now a single copy of what was left of
the manual is kept with
scp-158 at all times while most
instructions detailing the operation of
scp-158 did survive and were able to be
copied any chapters that might have
explained who built it or what it
actually did were too badly damaged to
read lost to the fire much like the
owner's manual all components of scp-158
the arm the console and the cables have
all appeared to sustain some amount of
fire damage but remain intact and in
full working order the damage is only
cosmetic and while it might take around
20 minutes to boot up this fire damage
doesn't affect the machine's function
but the question still remains what
exactly is the intended purpose of this
mechanical arm well through a long
process of trial and error and following
the surviving portions of the manual the
foundation was able to get the device
working again they learned that scp-158
will only perform its function when
presented with an ordinary living being
while human beings namely members of
d-class personnel are typically used as
test subjects by the foundation this
actually applies to any living creature
that has the ability to display
cognition which is the mental process of
gaining knowledge in order to perform
cognitive functions like thinking
remembering and problem solving when a
person or non-human being possessing
cognition is presented to scp-158
the machine will then go to work and
extract an unknown gas-based substance
from them this substance is then
deposited in the jar or beaker that is
then fitted to the dispenser beneath the
console so what does it take is it some
sort of advanced form of decontamination
device removing all toxins and
impurities from the body oh if only that
were true sadly you see the foundation
didn't give scp-158 the nickname of the
soul extractor for nothing after the
machine has performed its function the
now formerly cognitive organism on the
receiving end will display a complete
and total loss of their higher brain
functions they won't be able to speak
form coherent thoughts or even remember
who they were before
scp-158 was switched on the device will
rob them of any and all parts of
themselves essentially leaving the
person or creature as a hollowed-out
shell a husk of their previous self a
body without a soul perhaps even crueler
though is that this extraction process
is not fatal and victims are left alive
afterward they no longer possess their
capability for cognitive thought and
will not respond to any form of external
stimuli around them there have been some
level of brain stem activity recorded in
most cases and subjects have been known
to exhibit basic reflexes but this is
the only active movement they are now
capable of as for that substance that
test subjects have removed from their
bodies well it takes the form of a gas
as we mentioned earlier but it also
seems to be comprised of a mixture of
kinetic electrical heat and light energy
in fact each jar of the substance is an
infinite source of these various types
of energy albeit only capable of a very
low rate and output on average the
general consensus among foundation
researchers is that this substance is
the physical soul that has been removed
from a subject so
do they stay stuck as soulless shells
forever
actually scp-158 is in fact capable of
returning the extracted substance to a
subject that it performed a removal on
however whether a test subject normally
a member of d-class receives their soul
after having it extracted is all down to
whatever test is being conducted by the
foundation those that do get given their
souls back will usually regain access to
all of their previously lost cognition
and higher brain functions but the rate
at which they can return can vary
depending on the subject replacing the
substance from one patient with that of
another can also cause these results to
differ and again that's if the scp
foundation even bothers to replace a
test subject's soul instead of just
leaving them hollowed out it's actually
pretty terrifying to think that the
foundation has the freedom and the
capability to do that to somebody taking
away everything that makes someone a
human being only to leave their soul in
a jar while their vacant body lives on
without thought or consciousness it was
due to the unique anomalous function of
scp-158 that the device was proposed to
become a part of a foundation research
endeavor codenamed the olympia project
and overseen by its head researcher
professor kane pathos crow who has the
head of a golden retriever but that's a
story for another day the ultimate aim
of the project was to use the anomalous
properties of a number of scps to
successfully create an artificial human
that would become a potential asset of
the scp foundation as part of one series
of olympia project experiments professor
crowe gathered a group of d-class
personnel to undergo testing using
scp-158 each of these individuals had
been interviewed by crow himself and
were selected based on personality
traits and characteristics that the
professor liked or thought would be
useful to have in the foundation's
artificial humanoid the group chosen by
professor crowe featured a mix of male
and female test subjects as crow
believed a soul transcends the flesh it
is entered in the main purpose of the
experiment was to try and uncover some
of the further functions of scp-158
basically pushing the machine to its
limit trying to learn more information
about the device that would have been
contained in the damaged portions of the
owner's manual professor crowe had
poured over the sections that had
survived intact making sure he knew
every available piece of information on
scp-158
inside and out the obscured instructions
he was able to decipher were according
to his notes sketchy at best and
downright unhelpful at worst crow began
his experiments by removing the first
subject's soul and then trying to use
the device to do literally anything else
with the extracted substance despite
trying everything he could think of the
professor learned that there was little
the soul extractor could do with the
soul once it had been removed other than
reverse the process and return the
substance to the body it had been taken
from by then repeating this with further
d-class test subjects crow was able to
learn the exact input sequence needed to
reverse the soul extraction whilst
before this had only been ever achieved
through blind luck by his sixth
experiment with scp-158
professor crowe noticed that there was a
brief period in the middle performing
its function that the device would pause
as if awaiting further commands crowe
theorized that this pause was there for
additional sequences to be inputted via
the machine's console he then began
removing and re-implanting the same soul
into the following test subject both to
practice but also to experiment with the
soul extractor's controls the professor
found it strange that despite what he
was doing to her the d-class suffered
little to no side effects to her health
even though her soul was being
continuously removed and replaced then
on experiment number 11 crow seemed to
crack that little pause as cp 158 took
during each operation a new list of
commands appeared on the monitor like
split merge remove aspects add aspects
and combine aspects it seemed to the
professor that the device could be used
to not only remove souls but alter them
through his further experiments crowe
learned that the aspects the machine
mentioned were elements of a person's
personality such as willpower
understanding conscience creativity
empathy and the soul extractor could be
used to manipulate and rewrite a
person's entire identity before placing
it back into their body however this
took a considerable amount of testing
causing professor crow to grow more and
more frustrated with the complex
workings of the device that was until he
eventually realized it wasn't scp-158
that was too complicated for its own
good the machine was trying to quantify
the unquantifiable
explain something inexplicable the very
nature of the human soul professor crowe
began using scp-158 to modify a
composite soul which he referred to as
subject zero while working on it he
realized the soul itself seemed to be
aware of its surroundings possessing a
level of knowledge above that of most
foundation researchers including crow
himself either by fluke or by meddling
with scp-158
the professor had created a soul that
seemed to exist on several planes of
existence beyond the physical world that
we know
subject zero had become a sentient
disembodied consciousness an entity that
could see hear feel and think without
the need for a physical form or body to
house it zero was proposed to become
professor crowe's assistant given that
it displayed respect and admiration to
him for having created it almost like a
child looking up to a father figure all
it asked in return was to be given the
name other than subject zero crow told
the disembodied entity could name itself
whatever it liked the foundation then
planned for the composite soul now
formerly known as subject zero to be a
component of the olympia project's
artificial humanoid whenever its
creation was successfully completed
don't you just love a happy ending now
go check out living ice cream van
scp-1386
and
scp-261 pan-dimensional vending machine
for more peculiar anomalous machines
from the scp foundation